niger's Army has declared allegiance to
the leaders of Wednesday's coup the
chief of staff has released a statement
saying he doesn't want to see conflict
within the Armed Forces president
Muhammad bazoom was detained by members
of his presidential guard the group of
soldiers appeared on television blaming
him for deteriorating security and
economic mismanagement let's bring in
our correspondent Ahmed Idris he is
following developments from Abuja in
neighboring Nigeria and another twist in
This Crew Ahmed with the Army doing an
about turn and saying they support the
coup leaders
exactly the same Army that yesterday
told the world that they will Mutiny and
return president bazum to office the
only reason they gave for not interview
Boyd blackshit and now all of a sudden
24 hours later they are back in the cool
this Lent Credence to certain
suggestions within Niger that the
government of Muhammad bazoom was doomed
to fail was planned everything was
planned
part of complicated matters in the
country complicates matches on different
fronts complicated
number one is for bazoom and his family
secondly what is the fate of United
Nations United States and French bases
in
um uh Indonesia and they have options
now too either to stick with bazoom or
abandon him and go with the current flow
Indonesia and then suddenly it also
complicates the negotiations process
whatever
negotiation or mediation that is being
proposed to end this crisis amicably
will be in a difficult mode right now
simply because they are holding by Zoom
as a bargaining chip any intervention
will probably lead to undesirable
consequences there
and just before the Army said that they
were going to throw their support before
coup leaders we heard from the foreign
minister who said that he still believes
he still thinks of President bazoom as
president what's the potential here for
um for this crisis to escalate to Ahmed
with you know two sides one supporting
the president one supporting the coup
leaders and that being reflected on the
streets of Niger too
exactly uh that is complete for
complication number five simply because
if the protesters go ahead with their
plan to demonstrate on the streets of
the capital and other major cities that
could lead to confrontation between them
and the security forces which probably
could lead to blood uh Bloodshed and
there are also Pro coup supporters who
want to go out on this onto the streets
and support the Army for taking over or
overthrown president Muhammad bazoom
that could also lead to clashes between
the supporters of Bosa the basic
question is how long will this continue
how complicated here it will be very
very difficult and complicated in the
next few days in the next few weeks and
even months now all of that rest on
whether or not uh pro-democracy forces
externally and internally to take the
risk and walk that extra mile to ensure
that the protected in Asia
that will be the key and people will be
these forces United Nations United
States of America Europe across African
Union and other civil society
organizations whether or not they will
come out and must and walk the talk the
harsh words or the strong words we heard
yesterday whether or not they will be
able to live up to that will be the key
to resolving this crisis either
or violently all right up and thank you
very much for that that is I can address
with the latest from uh Abuja and
neighboring Nigerian apologies for the
uh poor sound the poor connection at
times there